en esta zona central de la capital
colombiana la vida parece haber vuelto a
la normalidad después de 5 meses de
confinamiento estricto los bogotanos
están autorizados a salir libremente a
la calle y los comercios han podido
retomar sus actividades
tenemos más movilidad y más
posibilidades de trabajar porque es que
el comercio estaba absolutamente quieto
perdido entonces ya podemos trabajar un
poco más un tercio de los más de 570.000
contagios del país han sido en bogotá la
alcaldesa claudia lópez anunció la
flexibilización de las medidas tras una
disminución del número de pacientes en
las unidades de cuidados intensivos en
las últimas semanas varios gremios
cayeron la reapertura de la economía a
pesar del miedo
ayer y esto el día con mucha gente mucho
tráfico de carros y mucha gente como si
las situaciones fuera normal cuando
realmente la pandemia y la pandemia
sigue pero de todas maneras pues no
trata de estar aislado de las demás
personas conserva la distancia y pues
tenemos que salir como sea llevarle el
pan de cada día a la casa a pesar de la
situación que está tan dura tan difícil
con el aumento del número de personas en
la calle el temor de nuevos contagios se
presente en la mente de muchas personas
es bastante irresponsable porque hay
muchísima gente y en este momento todos
estamos expuestos mira yo traigo 2
tapabocas y sin embargo realizamos el
cambio pero hay gente que lo utiliza
aquí entonces en realidad estamos
bastante expuestos que aunque deseamos
unas personas de 25 estamos en un rango
de aquí en este momento que seamos
jóvenes no quiere decir que no tengamos
digamos que no estamos dispuestos para
el contrario en colombia la siguiente
fase de apertura está prevista para el
próximo primero de septiembre con el fin
de las restricciones de desplazamiento
en todo el país